- You just wrapped your
first tour since coming out,
so how was this different?
Did you feel like, I don't know,
more comfortable, more at ease,
like more yourself?
- Well okay, so it's kind of funny.
There's this, before I came out,
you know, I had this section in my show.
I started this show before I came out,
and there's a part in
it called "Sportyland",
and Sportyland was
everybody's least favorite,
because it was just like,
we had like Candyland,
and then we had like BowBowland,
and then we had like Sportyland
and it was like baseball.
That's Sportyland actually.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [JoJo] And everyone didn't like it,
because the colors were
just like a little,
not pink and purple,
like it was just was
a full different vibe.
But then this round of tour,
you know, since coming out,
and like, not to be a stereotypical,
but like, it's a thing that
lesbians play softball.
Like it's just a thing.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my god.
- [JoJo] And so to have, it's a thing.
- And straight women, but yes.
- And straight women, well.
Well.
(audience laughing)
- And straight women.
I know straight women that play softball-
- I have played co-ed softball.
The one where you have the
pony keg at second base.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Did you say a pony keg at second base?
I wanna go to that softball.
- It's so great.
Okay.
- But, so it was like
everyone now like had this,
you know, we had our baseball bats,
and like, it was Sportyland.
It was like-
- Oh my gosh-
- The gayland.
- I love you so much.
- It ended up being everyone's favorite,
but it was so nice to be like, just free,
like people would bring-
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [JoJo] Pride flags and it was so cool.